one out of every four people tested for
covet 19
in arizona are is coming up positive
the highest rate in the country 90
percent of that state's icu beds are
full and the governor
is moving to increase testing mola
lenghi is at a testing facility in mesa
arizona
just outside phoenix moeller there don't
seem to be enough tests for everyone
that's right anthony that is the problem
right now look while
testing has improved by most standards
throughout the state in recent days
quest diagnostic the nation's largest
testing network is said on monday that
it could take up to seven
days for non-priority patients to get
their results up to a week-long wait
but now here at arizona state university
there might be a remedy to that problem
testing centers like this one we saw in
mesa arizona had people waiting weeks to
get an appointment
hours to get a test and almost another
week to get results
just seems like it's a really long wait
and that's why i almost didn't come
today
and that's part of the problem according
to the harvard global health institute
on
average arizona is testing 209 people
per 100 000 a day
but more than 1 000 need to be tested a
day to flatten the state's curve
and nearly 4 000 a day to fully suppress
new cases
it's a problem joshua le bear hopes to
solve we got
around 700 samples collected in only a
few hours
and all those results have already been
delivered labair is the executive
director of the biodesign institute
which held the first public covid test
last saturday that used a saliva
collection method designed by his team
at arizona state university the goal
quick collection and quick results so
just a matter of days it's about a day a
little bit more than a day
they're currently able to process up to
four thousand tests a day and hope to
scale up further
in goodyear arizona estrella contrera
and moyesis ramirez's parents
both caught covid19 in late june their
father
is now on a ventilator his hospital room
just happens to be on a first
floor with a window so his family set up
camp and they've been here
every single day we literally just speak
through the window as
loud as we can sometimes you can see
tears falling down
every single evening they speak to him
from outside the window
sometimes pray the rosary and let him
know they're still there
do you think maybe in some small way
that he knows you're out here that
that's helping
i believe so he'll yell at us but he
knows that we did it with heart
i'm sure you'll take that yelling at me
you'd accept that one
i'll take it any day
well the family camps outside their
father's window every day they're out
there in shifts all day all night
there is a family member out there and
often there will be other families who
they know or just perfect strangers who
will show up
offer up some food drinks water prayer
anything to show their support gail
it makes a difference to see people care
about you and support you always thank
you